how did this film come to you first of
all I guess you know my my my dad didn't
let me watch TV when I was younger I had
the apparatus but we didn't have cable
and I could have basically I had his
movies there and there were a lot of
epic films that he liked many of them
war films and I guess I decided I wanted
to create something epic but at the same
time something that spoke to what was
happening in the country where I'm from
Colombia that it had 60 years of civil
war and that you saw the potential of
peace the first potential for my
generation but the society is completely
polarized and had a very fragile
potential and so I hadn't seen a war
film from a country like Colombia had
seen it from maybe the United States of
Vietnam or France in Africa or England
in India but for a developing country
like Colombia where you have this in
regular conflict the idea came to me
that to tell a war film from the back
lines instead of from what we've seen
generally which are the front lines and
also tumour that film with a very you
know both incredible but conflictive
moment in your life which is adolescence
which you know you want to be alone but
you also want to belong your body
changes the timbre of your voice hair
comes out different places there's that
big metamorphosis so the idea was to
have these two conflicts the exterior
conflict that you see like in a war film
but also the interior conflict that of
adolescence and that you have actors
from the United States and actors and
known actors from Colombia can you talk
about the casting process in the United
States first we had we had this this
idea I had this idea of my my mind of
like Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
sorry it's just that's kind of what I
had and I had my I found my Snow White
and enjoy yeah Juliana had seen her work
and and I thought it was amazing she had
this very kind of an 8mm tenderness
sweetness but I don't think we had seen
a yet on
Green turn turn violent like it does and
so I thought that that kind of mother
relationship that she has at times
on-screen that the character of doctora
has Judea was able to portray and then
surprise us when she's able to you know
pay a heavy price to recover her liberty
and that's that that really blurs the
lines between victim and victimizer and
so that was something that Julianne
really really gave it all she had I mean
she was down there in Colombia for weeks
in a tent on a donkey in a raft and we I
mean we ran her through the model Israel
so you Lian you have been a stage
actress television actress film artist
don't different types of roles in your
life what attracted you to this
challenging role i thought the script
was amazing I thought it was unlike
anything I had ever read and I thought
that what Alejandra was just talking
about about young people and adolescence
and all that's raging through your body
paired with being in a war that felt
like a very exciting thing to explore
and I'd never played a role like this
and I loved the idea of going somewhere
else and and being in a new world and
and working with new people and I was
I'm so grateful to have been a part of
it it was not just an incredible work
experience but an incredible life
experience to have had this opportunity
once you land in Colombia please tell us
well we first went to the mountains
which was which felt sort of brutal in
its own way we stayed in a pretty simple
rustic retreat and I had I had like the
Queen suite up at the owner had a guest
bedroom but we would drive every day up
into chingus the national park and it
was an hour each way and of dirt road
with potholes the size of cars it was
very uncomfortable and when we'd get
there it was so beautiful but it was so
cold and so wet and every day people are
falling and
twelve thought how many it's about
thirteen it was really intense but then
that was like a walk in the park
compared to going to the jungle so I
tell people I'm from LA it's two planes
to Medellin and then you drive for three
hours on a paved road one hour on a dirt
road then you hike down an hour I opted
to not take the donkey down because I
heard it's scary going downhill on a
donkey and then a raft for an hour and
then we arrived at our camp and that's
where we were for three weeks with no
refrigeration no electricity no Wi-Fi
you know like you're we were pretty much
alone so what do you do when you have to
start interacting with this really very
diverse group of kids because these kids
if you look at their biographies some of
them are college students our kids come
from really dangerous neighborhoods a
real dichotomy of Colombian society you
know different social economic
backgrounds well basically we looked at
over 800 kids all around Colombia from
all sorts of places and we did it in
different ways we went to schools we
asked for videos over the Internet I
look for people when I was location
scouting I mean all that all the while
we were looking for this group and out
of the 800 I chose 30 let's say
finalists and we took them to this this
mountain camp that Julianne was
describing and we put them through
improv and acting exercises in the
morning in the afternoon they did
military exercises now we wanted them to
feel like a clandestine army so they
weren't doing any regular boot stomping
but different things sometimes barefoot
carrying a weapon and I found a
consultant a former guerrilla fighter
who had deserted the guerilla army and
he was there leading this so the kids
were actually sleeping together eating
together everything together and while
they were going through this sort of
mock boot camp I started to see the
chemistry's between them you know who
flirted with who who fought with who
and by seeing that many society form I
decide on and who would be the eight
Manos because the idea wasn't just how
each of them performed individually but
how they performed as an ensemble and I
rewrote the screenplay
during those during those weeks to make
sure that I wasn't just forcing the page
on to these kids but bringing these kids
lives onto on to the screenplay I got to
know them and that's I was able to bring
them to those those states of of acting
like like for example Smurfs who
Julianne has a very intense scene with
he's a kid from a very hard neighborhood
in Medellin but I knew that the most
important thing to him was his mother
and you know he has when he's tied to
the tree as such a job to do as an actor
and in front of Julian Nicholson and
that was that was tough but he was able
to really really make it happen and and
it was the youngest
yeah he's the youngest he was a 12 13
when one was shot and he's very
refreshing to see somebody like Rambo
a we thought the audience really caring
really needed to not mean no need to
know Rambo is a cure or a boy for Rambo
to be as important as he or she is and
it's very refreshing well the idea was
to I I know it makes us feel very
comfortable to divide the world in kind
of stickers is it from the left or the
right is a good or evils at Future past
as a boy or girl but the idea was for
the film to not allow you and and reject
any kind of binary notion of the world
so you don't know whether you're in the
past or in the future sometimes you
don't know if it's a boy or a girl
sometimes you don't know if you're in
paradise or you're in Hell and you don't
know if this is a paramilitary group
from the right wing or a guerrilla group
from the left wing and that forces you
to latch on to the humanity of the
present moment of the characters instead
of you know use your ideology or
ideological sympathies in some way you
know or prejudices which we all have
right now Colombia is watching your film
they has they have chosen your film even
to possibly compete at the Oscars well I
think the conflict in Colombia is an
irregular conflict as I said it's a
conflict that doesn't have those front
lines that we solved in a world war
or world war two and that conflict where
you have several guerrilla armies
several paramilitary armies the narcos
also foreign actors also the army
creates a sort of fog of war and that is
I think akin to the regular conflict
we're living in the world you hear your
grandparents speak about you know
fighting in Europe it's definitely not
what you see today in Syria and
Afghanistan the alliances shift all the
time there's a fog of war you don't know
exactly where you stand and so I think
this is a film that speaks to that in
regular conflict that we see today
and and in particularly to Colombia
which has gone through this type of a
civil war that's lasted 60 years and has
a very fragile peace right now it it's a
film that ask questions but not
questions as people with flags for
Colombians but us as a species as humans
as social animals and I think it's a
it's an ancestral question but a
question that we should ask ourselves
today you know who we are what do we
want to do where are we going and in
Colombia specifically what are we gonna
do for all the people that have deserted
or left these guerrilla armies and lay
down the weapons and what are they going
to do with us the biggest fear is that
you sign an agreement with the bosses of
these groups but then there's splinter
factions and they begin again and the
United States has has seen the effects
of that in the in the middle east and
that's why in the film Bigfoot starts
his own organization and in a way you
see the beginning at the end thank you
Julianne insane calahonda for being with
us here today